because there's one thing I know more  than anything more than the fact that I  know that the Sun will come up tomorrow  the thing that I know is that marketers  ruin everything  it's true right how many people here by  show of hands that know half-ass hands  again how many people here signed up for  Groupon LivingSocial daily candy one of  those sites raise your hand  great remember three four years ago how  you couldn't wait to get $40 worth of  sushi for 20 bucks that it was the  greatest thing that ever happened to you  well you don't open those emails anymore  right  you don't care if Groupon offers you a  million dollar home for a hundred bucks  you're like delete spam unsubscribe  because they sent you so much stuff that  you didn't want at scale right and so I  mean Google AdWords such an effective  scalable way to market and and they're  down 15% this year  I mean Google's reporting themselves  that clicks on AdWords are down 15%  habits are changing